okay Star Wars is big in my house big we
got the toys we go to all the movies
so my son says to me the other day he
says daddy we have a lightsaber fight in
the living room and I'm like yeah [ __ ]
yeah so now I'm in the living room
having a lightsaber fight with my son
you know we're having a good time look
over and I see my little girl Sophia
just locked in and she goes hey Daddy
she goes I want to have a lightsaber
fight with you too but I'm Darth Vader
and I said all right you know a little
weird you want to be on the dark side of
this age but
choosing evil at five is a little
concerning to a parent
it's like whatever you want my little
girl is holding this red lightsaber
twice the size of her body and we're
just you know going back and forth and
she cuts my leg off and I'm hopping on
one leg
then she cuts my arm off that's holding
the lightsaber I dropped the lightsaber
and I said oh sweetie you won you just
beat Daddy and in the most adorable
voice you people could ever imagine she
just goes not yet and put the [ __ ] to my
throat
and cut